[Música]
[Aplausos]
hay quienes dicen que somos como
cangrejos que cuando alguien quiere
salir del barril de jalan hacia abajo y
esto se repite hasta que ya nadie se
quiere mover
yo creo que las personas se parecen más
a los elefantes cuando un elefante está
cruzando el camino los demás elefantes
se ponen atrás y lo empujan para
ayudarlo a salir y es que el mundo no es
como un barril de cangrejos que está
estático él no se está transformando
continuamente y hoy se está
transformando en un mundo digital hoy
desde un celular
puedes comprar leer un libro de un taxi
bailar en la tienda rentar una casa y mi
favorita puedes por una suscripción
tener toda la música que te puedas
imaginar y llevarla donde tú quieras
esa es la transformación digital y la
mayoría de estas empresas
crecieron y nacieron digitales pero hoy
más empresas tradicionales están
intentando hacer el cambio al mundo
digital
en el 2015 se publicó un estudio llamado
el vórtice digital vórtice porque se
comporta como un remolino donde las
empresas se enfrentan a dos opciones en
sus distintas industrias es un poco
caótico de repente chocan entre sí y se
acelera con el tiempo y dentro de las
conclusiones que nos dice este estudio
es 4 de cada 10 empresas dominantes va a
desaparecer en tres años es decir ya
y la otra es que aunque la mitad de la
gente se está dando cuenta del riesgo
sólo una tercera parte está tomando
acción con ellos
no como los taxistas mexicanos
que jamás se imaginaron que en cuatro
años iba a llegar hubiera competirles
y su mentalidad de cangrejo los hizo
rechazar la amenaza hacer propaganda
negativa
el día que fueron a bloquear las calles
para protestar mi sitio de taxis
favorito decidió bloquear mi lugar de
trabajo
ese día me convertí en usuario de uber
la mentalidad de cangrejo consiguió el
resultado opuesto al que estaban
buscando
y es que empresas gobiernos y países
tienen que entender que no son una
burbuja en el mundo son jugadores
globales nos guste o no nos guste la
transformación digital llegó para
quedarse así como la revolución
industrial
y tenemos algunos retos para lograr esta
transformación la primera es la
tecnología
como este martillo una tecnología que
permite transformar la energía de mi
cuerpo concentrada en un punto como es
un clavo y lograr que pende de una
superficie dura como la pared realmente
es una tecnología increíble
pero la tecnología es solamente una
herramienta la podemos utilizar para lo
que fue diseñada podemos tratar de
vernos creativos hacer algo de arte con
ella o podemos ser destructivos
y crear un caos pensando que vamos a
sacar valor capital y solamente creamos
destrucción pero la culpa no fue de la
tecnología no fue del martillo
otro ejemplo un poco más reciente la
inteligencia artificial creada en los
50s tanto empresas como academia por
muchos años por décadas trabajaron en
tener aplicaciones útiles cuando se
lograron otras empresas que utilizaron
para mejorar su productividad pero fue
ahí donde empezó la preocupación de la
pérdida de empleos y ahí entra la
sociedad civil las ongs que meten
presión y proponen soluciones para que
tanto empresas como gobiernos
reducir a la gente impactada para que su
situación inclusive mejore con trabajos
de más responsabilidad y mejor
remunerados
nuestro siguiente gran reto es el
talento gente capacitada hace 20 años se
formó la academia de redes networking
academy
en sociedad con distintas universidades
alrededor del mundo hoy tiene más de
1.700.000 estudiantes pero esto no es
suficiente
en este estudio de índice que intenta
medir cuál es la brecha de conocimiento
en redes en latinoamérica nos dice que
todas tenemos un hueco de una tercera
parte es decir uno de cada tres empleos
en tecnología no se puede llenar por
falta de gente y la industria no está
cerrando esta brecha ni con inteligencia
artificial ni con tecnologías de cloud
nosotros damos pláticas a los alumnos de
la academia para compartir las
tendencias de tecnología darles consejos
de carrera
y para recomendarles que estudien inglés
porque un ingeniero sin inglés cómo
aprender en la mañana es como tratase de
abrochar un zapato con una sola mano no
es imposible pero es mucho más difícil y
mucho más lento
les contamos historias que los inspiren
como el doctor garcía luna un mexicano
con más de 60 patentes que han
transformado las redes de computadoras
de todo el mundo
hacemos eventos enfocados en mujeres
simplemente porque si queremos resolver
un problema sería muy estúpido hacerlo
con la mitad de los recursos disponibles
necesitamos hombres y mujeres por igual
como lo hizo ainstein cuando él quería
probar su teoría general de la
relatividad tenía algunos retos con las
matemáticas y fue la universidad de
göttingen a pedir ayuda y fue la doctora
eminente la que le solucionó el problema
y todo esto suena muy bien pero hay
veces que dudas dudas que estás haciendo
una diferencia que estés haciendo un
impacto con estas cosas hace unos años
fui a dar una plática a una universidad
y antes de empezar le pregunté a la
audiencia quiénes estaban o quiénes
habían ido el año anterior a la plática
y quiénes habían aceptado mi reto de
empezar a estudiar inglés nadie levantó
la mano nadie
salgo de la plática y en el pasillo
había estudiantes más interesados en el
fútbol de las pantallas que entrar a
aprender algo nuevo y superarse y salí
muy triste y decepcionado
afortunadamente tiempo después me
presentaron un ex alumno que estaba
platicando su historia él mencionó que
después de una de estas pláticas salió
inspirado decidido a mejorar en sus
estudios que iban un poco mal decidió
certificarse y tratar de trabajar con
nosotros y lo logró en su charla
menciona que esa plática cambió su vida
y ese comentario a mí me dio la
fortaleza para nunca más volver a
cuestionar el valor que tiene dedicarle
tiempo a la educación y a la juventud
el siguiente reto
es un poco más difícil es lograr que
todo un país se transforme a una
economía digital
en conjunto con gartner se desarrolló
este índice que intenta medir qué tan
listo está un país para transformar su
economía en una economía digital
ya hablamos nosotros de la tecnología
del capital humano y hablamos un poquito
de la necesidad de gobiernos y de
empresarios que inviertan en esta
transformación digital y crean otras dos
métricas muy interesantes una la
facilidad de hacer negocios respetando
la ley es decir
respetar la propiedad intelectual y
estar en un mercado no se puede competir
justamente la otra son las necesidades
humanas básicas porque también vieron
hoy que una persona con conectividad a
internet tiene acceso a un sinfín de
herramientas que pueden transformar la
vida por completo pero si esa persona
tiene hambre no tiene dónde dormir no va
a poder extraer valor esa tecnología
este mapa muestra en tres grandes etapas
cómo se encuentran los distintos países
en su evolución los países desarrollados
se encuentran en etapa de amplificar lo
que vienen haciendo
la mayoría de nuestros países
latinoamericanos se encuentran en una
etapa intermedia que es una etapa de
acelerar esfuerzos que venimos haciendo
méxico se encuentra no en una muy buena
posición tenemos mucho por hacer tenemos
varios países por delante nosotros
uruguay chile colombia costa rica panamá
yo estoy convencido que todos podemos
ser solucionadores de problemas globales
si pensamos globalmente pero ejecutamos
localmente haciendo un efecto
multiplicador hace algunos años el
gobierno de mi ciudad decidió cambiar el
uso del suelo de una zona protegida
unas barrancas que aportan casi el 70%
el agua potable de la ciudad
yo fui a la junta de vecinos básicamente
porque mi esposa me mandó es decir mucha
opción no tenía y fui molesto fui con un
sentimiento de impotencia de que iba a
perder mi tiempo y que no iba a lograr
absolutamente nada y grande fue mi
sorpresa que bien organizados logramos
revertir esa decisión y fue esa pequeña
gran victoria que me hizo pensar cuando
vi este anuncio de mexicanos contra la
corrupción ven a escucharnos fui a la
plática y salí comprometido a darles un
pequeño donativo mensual y a través de
los meses viendo los resultados de sus
investigaciones y publicaciones con la
prensa libre
me sentía orgulloso orgulloso de haber
dado un granito de arena a combatir ese
gran mal
y muy emocionado me fui con mi equipo de
trabajo a platicarles todas estas
historias y los invite a meterse a
transparencia internacional y firmar la
declaración contra la corrupción después
de tres horas había conseguido 65
personas
y eso me puso a reflexionar yo había
pasado la mayor parte de mi carrera
enfocado en mi trabajo en el negocio y
de repente ayudar un poco a la academia
pero había dos grandes áreas donde yo no
estaba trabajando en mi vida uno como
ciudadano como el que no me con el
gobierno como peso y contrapeso y otra
como parte de la sociedad civil tomando
parte de mi responsabilidad en la
responsabilidad social
y es que este modelo le hacemos falta a
cada uno de nosotros como una estrella
en el centro porque cada individuo es
una estrella que puede dar luz a la
sociedad
y como si se alinearán las estrellas al
poco tiempo me invitaron a participar en
la fundación de la empresa y me pasó
como cuando ves el mar por primera vez
te sorprendes de la inmensidad del
océano me encontré un mundo de ongs
enorme enfocadas en salud en educación
en combatir el hambre en dar el apoyo
económico en transformar al mundo y me
acordé de este dicho que dice camina tan
lejos como alcances saber y cuando
llegues allá vas a poder ver mucho más
allá
como la película mexicana nosotros los
nobles donde javi el niño rico trata de
convencer a su papá de poner un negocio
con nueve gasolineras a domicilio y todo
méxico se votó de la risa
pero cuidado que esa es nuestra
mentalidad de cangrejo en acción hoy hay
más de media docena de estas empresas en
eeuu dando el servicio a precios
competitivos con menos contaminación y
cambiando la vida a muchos de sus
usuarios
eso es ver más allá
y yo vengo aquí ahora
a convencerlos de que ustedes también
pueden ayudar a hacer este cambio puede
empezar con algo muy sencillo para
trascender cómo hacer el juramento en
múltiple diversity para promover equipo
y talento diverso super rock es uno de
los talentos que yo me comprometió a
promover por su maravilloso trabajo y
ustedes también pueden hacer la
diferencia para alguien más
si llevan calentando motores
la iniciativa global problem solvers
son unas caricaturas que están en
español también de un grupo de chavos
con habilidades digitales
y viene acompañado en jeep y es de civis
de una serie de formatos que puedes
bajar para profesores y para padres lo
puedes llevar
a tu escuela secundaria a una escuela
rural no vean los pueden usar de
conejillo de indias a sus vecinos a sus
primos y ustedes aunque no sean
ingenieros pueden ayudar a disminuir
esta brecha de talento que tenemos
y todos podemos ser parte de los grandes
problemas del mundo
todas estas ongs combaten la corrupción
de una forma o de otra
entren a sus páginas vean de qué se
trata qué hacen en qué se pueden
involucrar
métase a transparencia internacional y
busca la declaración contra la
corrupción invite en alguien más que la
firme
o estas otras que combaten el hambre
tienen programas con escuelas
porque recuerden una persona con hambre
no puede extraer valor ni a la
tecnología ni al conocimiento
siendo ustedes no le ha regalado un café
a un amigo
por el precio de un café al mes pueden
hacer una donación que ayuda a cambiar
el mundo y al país y sentirse orgullosos
que está hablando su granito de arena y
si todavía no llego a convencerlos y
están pensando porque dar mi tiempo y mi
dinero les voy a dar dos razones la
primera es porque así ustedes pueden
ayudar a transformar a méxico en una
economía digital más próspera
y justa para todos
atacando con estas tres acciones
el índice de talento la facilidad de
hacer negocios combatiendo la corrupción
y hacer un país más justo con las
necesidades humanas básicas
y la otra y es que cuando ustedes dan un
poquito a los demás se les regresa de
formas inimaginables por ejemplo a mí me
tocó un premio que me llegó de una
asociación que yo no conocía hi tec y
tienen un lema 'tus shop to love empuja
hacia arriba y jala los demás el lema me
encantó es un grupo de ejecutivos en
tecnologías de información latinos en
eeuu que encontraron que hay en común en
nuestras culturas latinas para apoyarse
mutuamente una verdadera mentalidad de
elefante
y cuando estaba yo reflexionando
para mi discurso de agradecimiento no
pensando en todas esas personas que me
habían ayudado al camino me habían dado
una oportunidad
incluyen la persona que me había
nominado me puse a pensar y como pueden
ver hay más mujeres que hombres y es que
la diversidad retribuye es más fácil que
una mujer se tome el tiempo de llenar
una nominación para que tú te lleves un
premio a que lo haga un hombre nosotros
somos un poquito más flojos pero todos
ellos son parte de mi constelación le
dan luz a mi vida y me iluminan en el
camino
y yo espero haberles otorgado un poquito
de mi luz y los invito a que se
conviertan en una constelación más de
mexico porque recuerden las estrellas
son fugaces con las constelaciones son
inquebrantables las constelaciones son
para siempre muchas gracias
[Aplausos]